So far, we've only
been requesting the server
to send data to us
using the GET method.
However, sometimes you
might want the user
to type in some data
or upload a picture
and send that to the server.
This is where the POST
method comes into play
that we mentioned earlier.
With a POST request, the
request itself can also
have a payload, or
body, something we
have already seen in
responses but not in requests.
What exactly happens
to the data once it
has been sent to the server is
up to the back-end developer
and is not in the
scope of this course.
It is, however, important to
know that POST requests are
potentially handled differently
by proxies and the browser
than GET requests.
Have you ever seen one of these?
This is what happens when
the page you're currently
looking at was the
result of a POST request.
If you try to reload
such a website,
the browser will prompt you
to confirm this reload action,
as POST requests are allowed
to be destructive operations,
and repeating it might be more
destructive than you originally
intended.
That's why it is
usually recommended
for the back-end
developer to not
respond to a POST request with
a web site but with a redirect,
to avoid this rather
jarring behavior.
For the user, this redirect
is practically invisible
but avoids the
problems of a reload.